هنا اسال محمد الطيب من حيث المعموره في
الجنوب ووراء كخلفك كما يبدو حافله للنقل
وهي الان هي مقصد كل السودانيين الراغبين
للخروج او الهروب من هذا الواقع المقلق
والمخيف كيف ترصد لنا المشهد هناك وان
تتحدث في مراسلات سابقه عن
الغلاء الفاحش او الثمن الغالي جدا الذي
يدفعه الراغبون في المغادره
ويعني استغلال اصحاب هذه الحافلات حاجات
الناس للمغادره برفع اسعار التذاكر
نعم عبد الصمد اليوم الاول في الهدنه كما
تلاحظون نحن في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم في
تقاطع شارع الستين مع شارع جوبا هذا اليوم
يعتبر الحركه في الشارع اكثر انتعاشا على
مدى
العشره ايام الماضيه
وتلاحظون هناك عدد
كبير من الحافلات والبساطه السفريه
التي جاءت الى هذه المنطقه بالتحديد
باعتباري ان الكثافه السكانيه فيها عاليه
هذه احدى المناطق المتاخمه للعمليات
العسكريه التي وقعت فبالتالي يحاول
المواطنون الخروج من مناطق واحيا الكويت
الطائف الرياض باعتبار هذه الاحياء تشهد
عمليات عسكريه
كثيفه منهم من ينتظر منهم من يحاول ان ان
يجد ما يقله الى منطقته في هذه المنطقه
بالتحديد هناك عدد من الحافلات السفريه
تتحول تذهب الى دنقله والى بورسودان والى
حلفا والى ولايات السودان المختلفه الاخرى
والمشكله التي رواها لنا عدد كبير من
المواطنين الذين
التقينا بهم ان الاسعار التذاكر هي اصبحت
والناقلات الناس هذه الحافلات والباصات
منها من وجد من يركبه والاخر لم يجد بحكم
ان اسعار التذاكر شبه غاليه وجنونيه
وبالتالي تكمن هناك مشكله في الحصول على
الكاش لهؤلاء الناس اليوم يعتبر اكثر
الايام انتعاشا الذي شاهدناه في هذه
المنطقه غطينا خلال الايام الماضي في هذه
في هذه المناطق ومناطق اخرى من العاصمه في
جنوب الخرطوم لكن اليوم اكثر انتاجا على
ما يبدو هناك اطمنان للهدنه من قبل
المواطنين ولذلك هذا الخروج نعتبره الاكثف
والاكثر من المواطنين الذين يسكنون في هذه
المناطق
المتاخمه للعمليات العسكريه وبالتالي هناك
امل في ان هذه الهدنه لن تخرق او انها لن
تصل الى مراحل كما حصل في الهودنات
الماضيه في يهودنا يوم عيد الفطر كان هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه
وهذا كان
خارج توقعات الناس اليوم الحركه تبدو
دؤوبه في المناطق المخارج نحن الان في
المخرج الجنوبي للخرطوم الذي يؤدي الى الى
الى ولايه الجزيره ومنها الى مدني ومن ثم
الى بورسودان والقضارف والولايات الشرقيه
بالنسبه للدوله
منها هذه الحافلات هل هي امنه حتى يعامرها
هؤلاء بالمغادره علما حتى ان البعثرات
الدبلوماسيه كما افاد بذلك المراسلون
اجانب ومراسلون ايضا في بورسودان تعرض لي
ايضا لصعوبات امنيه والرئيس الفرنسي تحدث
عن اصابه جوندي
فرنسي خلال العمليات الاجزاء هؤلاء الذين
يعابرون يغادرون الان عبر الحافلات هل هل
وصولهم امنين مضمون
[موسيقى]
اه في في ظل الاوضاع الحاليه والسيول
الامنيه لا نستطيع ان نقول ان الشارع امن
بنسبه مئه في المئه بحكم ان هناك حوادث
تعرضت لها عدد من المواطنين وهناك حوادث
تعرض لها تم الاعلان عنها هناك عوارض تعرض
لها ايضا عدد من المواطنين الذين كانوا
يستقلوا لكن ليست هي بالحوادث التي نستطيع
انها نقول انها كبيره
وكثيفه فبالتالي الوضع في ظل الاوضاع
الحاليه ليست هناك وجود
العمليات العسكريه والجهات الفعليه التي
تقوم بواجب التامين وما الى ذلك من
الاشياء ربما هي منشغله نوعا ما بما يحصل
في الخرطوم لكن الجيش اعلن في بيان له
سابق بانه يسعى الى تامين هذه المناطق بعض
المناطق واغلب هذه المناطق التي نتحدث
عنها في الولايات هي تحت السيطره القوات
المسلحه السودانيه لذلك الجيش حريص
حريص دائما على ان يكون الناس في هذه
المناطق وهذه المخارج الرئيسيه في مامن
لانه تولى عمليه اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
واعلن عن ذلك انه هو المسؤول عن هذه
العمليه فبالتالي هو حريص على ان تكون هذه
الشوارع امنه ولا يتعرض
الذين يمشون فيها والذين يسلكونها الى شكل
من اشكال المخاطر الانبياء التي قد تودي
بحياته ورغم ارتفاع اسعار تذاكر كما قلت
هل الاماكن متوفره في هذه الحافلات
الاماكن متوفره في عدد من الحافلات
الحافلات كثرتها ووقوفها يعني انها في
حاله
استقرار لعلنا نحاول ان ندخل هذه الحافله
اذا استطعنا الى ذلك سبيلا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله قناتي الجزيره
الحافله
اسوان سعر التذكره كم لاسوان
التذكره 260
بتاخد كم ساعه الى
يومين
وقعدت تشحن بسهوله هل في ركاب بيمشوا من
هنا ولا كلهم رقابه كثيرين والله الناس دي
كلها
الجاهزه الان الجالون
محمد طيب
يعني باعتبار انكم الذين
من الخرطوم الى اسوان
على الله ما معروف
هل سمعت بحوادث تعرض لها باصات سفريه خلال
الايام الماضيه
شكرا جزيلا لك بالتالي عبد الصمد يعني هذه
البساطه تتحرك من هنا من قلب الخرطوم حتى
تصل الى مدينه اسوان في جنوب مصر
يعني اشكرك يا محمد
الى منطقه الى هذه المره يومين من الطريق
ومن السفر ستكون مرهقه لمن يعني يذهبون بي
ويسلكون هذا الطريق
ويبدو من جواب السائق وكان رحله محفوفه
بالمجهول او رحله نحو المجهول اتمنى لهم
السلامه شكرا لك على كل حال محمد الطيب من
حي المعموره جنوب الخرطوم